ahora
[Música]
bienvenidos a este avance informativo de
france 24
soy valentina torre sánchez desde niza
en el sur de francia el presidente
emmanuel macrón anunció nuevas medidas y
envió un mensaje de unidad tras el
atentado con cuchillo registrado esta
mañana en la basílica de nuestra señora
en el centro de la ciudad en el que tres
personas perdieron la vida el
responsable de los hechos permanece bajo
custodia el mandatario anunció que
aumentará de tres mil hasta entre cuatro
mil y siete mil el pie de fuerza en el
territorio francés principalmente en
colegios y lugares de culto esto fue lo
que dijo hace algunos minutos
el mandatario abogó por la unidad
nacional y recordó que con este atentado
están bajo ataque los valores de
libertad en francia
en francia no hay una comunidad es la
comunidad nacional le quiero decir a
todos nuestros conciudadanos sin
importar su religión si creen o no creen
en este momento debemos unirnos y no
ceder ante el espíritu de división ni en
el balance de distrito edificio por su
parte el primer ministro francés franck
hasta que anunció que el país entró en
máximo estado de alerta tras el atentado
se trata del tercer ataque en dos meses
que las autoridades han atribuido a
extremistas musulmanes castex señaló que
este es un atentado contra las
libertades de culto y de conciencia
la respuesta del gobierno será firme
implacable e inmediata de inmediato
por lo tanto ya he decidido elevar el
sistema de alerta al nivel de emergencia
y de ataque en todo el territorio
nacional con el alcalde de la ciudad de
niza christian estrosi indicó que su
ciudad y francia están pagando un precio
muy alto por el fascismo islamista a su
vez el diputado conservador eric ciotti
quien estuvo en la reunión de emergencia
con el jefe de estado pidió la
suspensión del flujo migratorio y de las
solicitudes de asilo desde la frontera
italiana por su parte de la alcaldesa de
parís anne hidalgo manifestó su apoyo a
las autoridades locales
quiero dirigir mis pensamientos a las
víctimas y sus allegados afectados por
este ataque horrible ojalá una vez más
los habitantes de niza se ven afectados
mis socios y es alcalde christian
estrosi le quiero decir que puede contar
con el apoyo de la ciudad de parís los
parisinos y las parisinas bach y de
paciencia en el país
con la misa al igual que francia puede
que otros lugares en el país hoy está
pagando un precio muy alto siendo una
vez más víctimas del fascismo islamista
y el islamofascismo no hay ninguna duda
de que el autor de esos actos no dejaba
de repetir en bucle delante de nosotros
que alá es grande mientras recibía
atención médica en el lugar ese era el
sentido de su actuar
el presidente emmanuel macrón hace unos
minutos desde niza anunció que aumentará
hasta tres de tres mil hasta entre
cuatro mil y siete mil el pie de fuerza
en el territorio francés principalmente
en colegios y lugares de culto esto fue
lo que aseguró el mandatario
esta mañana decidimos aumentar la
vigilancia en toda francia para
adaptarnos a la amenaza terrorista
decidí que nuestros militares estarán en
las próximas horas más movilizados y
pasaremos en el marco de la operación
centinela de tres mil y siete mil
militares en nuestro territorio así
tendremos la posibilidad de proteger a
todos los lugares de culto
particularmente las iglesias para que la
fiesta de todos los santos pueda
celebrarse en el total seguridad también
protegeremos en nuestras escuelas para
la próxima semana
su doble condición
y tras estos hechos los legisladores
franceses guardaron un minuto de
silencio por las víctimas del ataque con
cuchillo en misa además de suspender la
sesión que realizaban sobre las nuevas
medidas para contener la pandemia de el
coronavirus
y es que francia no solo está viviendo
lo ocurrido en niza en la ciudad de lyon
fue detenido esta mañana un hombre
afgano que portaba un cuchillo y se
disponía a entrar a un tranvía así mismo
fuentes policiales confirmaron que un
hombre que amenazaba a transeúntes con
un arma de fuego en la ciudad de aviñón
murió por disparos de agentes los
oficiales le pidieron que se deshiciera
del arma pero al rehusarse abrieron
fuego por último un guardia de seguridad
del consulado francés en la ciudad
saudita de jeddah fue atacado con arma
blanca
las autoridades condenaron el ataque y
aseguraron que nada puede justificarlo
entretanto el gobierno turco emitió un
comunicado en el que condena
enérgicamente el ataque terrorista
perpetrado en niza y destacó que ninguna
razón puede justificar el asesinato de
una persona o justificar la violencia el
ministerio de exteriores afirmó que
quienes organizan un ataque tan brutal
en un lugar sagrado de culto no respetan
los valores religiosos humanitarios y
morales el presidente macrón desde niza
también envió un mensaje de unidad y
recordó que con este atentado están bajo
ataque los valores de libertad en
francia
en francia no hay una comunidad es la
comunidad nacional le quiero decir a
todos nuestros conciudadanos sin
importar su religión si creen o no creen
en este momento debemos unirnos y no
ceder ante el espíritu de división ni en
el balance de al espíritu edificio
esperé a partir de las 12 horas de
bogotá quito lima un especial de
noticias sobre el ataque terrorista
perpetrado hoy en niza las reacciones y
los demás hechos que dejan a francia en
una nueva jornada de luto llegamos al
final de este avance informativo
gracias por su sintonía y continúen con
más en france 24